And now for the answer.
The correct answer after all we've discussed, of course, is relevant,
meaning that every single information that remains in the input,
changes the outcome if it is changed as well.
If we say that Mozilla crashes with these 8 characters,
removing any of these characters changes the outcome.
Therefore, all of these 8 characters are relevant for the failure of Mozilla.
Of course, this input also is simple, but this is not necessarily always the case.
You can have very, very complex failures where lots and lots of information is relevant
but still hard to understand and therefore not necessarily simple.
Everything is correct. I don't know what a correct input is.
This cannot be generalized.
Elegant? Well, I'm not sure what an elegant test case is.
There is elegant code and elegant fixes,
but this does not necessarily apply.
So, the correct answer is relevant.